[Musique]
il croit qu'il peut se battre comme son
grand-père
ça suffit allez-y continuez je voudrais
visite à vos pères les uns après les
autres
dans la vie la seule façon de se
protéger
cette combattre
il n'a pas ce qu'il faut pour devenir
comme toi
laisse-le tranquille
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs un certain James
[Musique]
et je te mettrai au sommet
[Applaudissements]
le combat permet un pauvre de devenir un
prince
notre premier contact avec la haute
société
[Musique]
il finiras comme ton grand-père je suis
pas comme lui maman attention faites
attention
considère les combattants comme un moyen
de gagner de l'argent laissez-moi vous
présenter nripeers tu n'as jamais
combattu quelqu'un comme lui avant il va
venir te chercher il faut que tu te
demandes
est-ce que tu veux vraiment ça
le combat du championnat on en parle
dans tout le pays
bien frais combattant maintenant j'ai
déjà suffisamment lutté il croit en toi
James comme nous tous
il faut savoir qui on est dans la
vie on t'attendre et remplis et que ta
chair pourri tout ce que tu laisses
derrière toi
tu peux être
une chance
champion d'Angleterre
[Musique]